thirty seconds and counting
the night before that feels good you
know a 25 before 1988 astronomers knew
of only eight planets in the entire
universe those around the Sun today we
know of nearly 4,000 these are called
exoplanets and they orbit stars outside
of our solar system the majority are so
distant when they're not moving that
little can be learned about these
exoplanets we do not know if any support
life but over the years advances in
telescope technology have made it easier
to detect them launched in 2009 a space
telescope called Kepler has been
responsible for finding the majority of
the exoplanets we know today by staring
at a single patch of the sky it found
them as they passed in front of their
stars but Kepler could only focus on
planets around lots of distant stars
[Music]
Kepler is now retired it's been replaced
with a new telescope liftoff the SpaceX
Falcon 9 carrying tests a planet-hunting
spacecraft that will search for new
worlds beyond our solar system tests
which can scan the entire sky and is
equipped with four special cameras it
will look at around 200 thousand
pre-selected stars that are closer and
among the brightest is seen from Earth
over its two-year mission Tess is
expected to discover hundreds of
thousands of new planets like Kepler it
will be able to detect the proximity of
planets to their stars providing
astronomers with some information about
their possible climates because tests
will find planets that are comparatively
near to Earth other bigger telescopes
will be able to take a more detailed
look including looking for the presence
of liquid water
if there is alien life out there Tess
could play an important role in finding
it
[Music]
coming up next Thursday could space be
the next frontier for war